[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video i'm going to be discussing
malfoy and i'm not talking about draco
or lucius
i'm not even talking about abraxas i'm
going to be talking about draco malfoy's
great great great grandfather brutus one
of the most prejudiced wizards of his
era
i can't say this with complete certainty
because there are gaps in the malfoy
family tree
but i suspect that brutus is the son of
lucius malfoy the first
who far preceded the lucius malfoy that
we know from the harry potter story
ruchus was born sometime in the early to
mid 1600s
while lucius we are familiar with was
born in 1953
between those two men however are in
chronological order
septimus malfoy who was born sometime
between 1770 and 1780
and abraxas malfoy lucius father man
you've probably heard of before
abraxas was draco's grandfather and was
born sometime in the early 1900s
with this information i feel that we can
safely infer that brutus was the
great-great-grandfather
of lucius and
great-great-great-grandfather of draco
when we think of the malfoy family
lineage certain words come to most
people's minds
but these words scarcely hold a positive
connotation
usually when someone says malfoy you
might think
bigot or prejudiced but that's a
reputation that was earned
through centuries of intolerance these
are characteristics almost ingrained in
their bloodline
and it wasn't until really draco that
this intolerance began to waver somewhat
historically they are a wealthy family
of morally crooked witches and wizards
that will whimper when caught red-handed
and gloats when in a position of power
it is often said of the malfoy family
that you will never find one at the
scene of the crime
though their fingerprints might be all
over the guilty wand independently
wealthy with no need to work for a
living
they have generally preferred the role
of power behind the throne happy for
others to do the donkey's work
and to take the responsibility for
failure they have helped finance many of
their preferred candidates election
campaigns
which have it is alleged included paying
for dirty work such as hexing the
opposition
but after doing some research i think
i've managed to find the most awful
malfoy
brutus let's kick things off with one of
his quotes nothing
is a surer sign of weak magic than a
weakness for non-magical company
this is a clear representation of the
mindset of brutus malfoy
a british pureblood wizard who happened
to be the editor of the anti-muggle
periodical
warlock at war it's probably no surprise
to you that brutus was prejudiced
towards muggleborns
but that alone wasn't good enough for
him he was intent on targeting and
exposing
anyone and everyone that would even dare
to fraternize with muggles or
muggleborns
it was an advocate of the fact that
witches and wizards who associated with
muggles
lacked magical talent an entirely skewed
perspective
likely fabricated out of hate from the
beadle and the bard book
influential wizards of the day such as
brutus malfoy editor of warlock at war
and anti-muggle periodical perpetuated
the stereotype that a muggle lover
was about as magical as a squib in 1675
brutus wrote
this we may state with certainty any
wizard who shows fondness for the
society of muggles
is of low intelligence with magic so
feeble and pitiful
that he can only feel himself superior
if surrounded by muggle pigmen
nothing is a sure sign of weak magic
than a weakness for non-magical company
what likely induced this perspective
however was the era that brutus was born
into
during his lifetime persecution of
witches and wizards by muggles was at
its height
the magical and muggle worlds were
interwoven somewhat and tensions were
high
anti-muggle sentiment was popular and
widespread brutus was just a strong
advocate of spreading the message
what made him truly evil however was
that he used his influence and his
platform for evil
a large platform can be as sinister as
any tool in the wrong hands
and brutus truly took advantage of his
editorial position
what i can say however is that
fortunately his message wasn't powerful
enough for witches and wizards to ignore
the absolute fact
that fraternizing with muggleborns had
no relevance to magical capability
the prejudice eventually died out in the
face of overwhelming evidence that some
of the world's most brilliant wizards
were
to use the common phrase muggle lovers
though there are a few references to
brutus and harry potter canon some have
suspected that he may have appeared in a
portrait in the malfoy manor
that's it for this video had you guys
heard of brutus before let me know in
the comment section
below until next time there is plenty to
be learned even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
you